with dignity and respect
committed to free speech common sense
and entertaining straight talking and
direct we may have each other hello and
welcome to the pledge now a London
bookshop was embroiled in a very British
scandal this week after a practical joke
had decided to improve its copies of
David Cameron's autobiography for the
record revamping the cover with
embellished reviews such as a very great
book so great no it's a great book all
the words all the pages that was from
President Rob Tarrant terrible and
making a magnet tweak to the verb on the
back quotes written by a tired man with
a face like a satellite dish made
entirely of ham now it turns out or
panel or a literary lot who've been
beavering away over the years penning
their own bestsellers I couldn't wait to
make mischief by adding some finishing
touches to these treasured page-turners
but it turned out there was no need
their comedy gold already so Gregg's
Inside Story is a pacing run according
to the observer according to dick
Ferrari oh yes it's adorned by glowing
praise from Carol Thatcher that quote
NIC is exquisite fun to be with
Michele do breeze is quotes anything
possible which promises a journey quotes
from the checkout to The Apprentice and
beyond look at the hair
don't think you've got away with it
Carol and not that easily we've
unearthed and not at all tampered with
version of your masterpiece turn back
time on brexit the highs and lows of a
remoter in modern-day Britain the
struggle is real
Carroll for you coming up Greg offers
some advice to Harry and Meagan Michele
argues there isn't a time limit on
justice I'm asking what's wrong with a
good old-fashioned three-piece suit and
fenneis all fired up
but first Carole okay it takes a special
kind of stupidity to snatch a disaster
from triumph but our dithering
politicians did it again this week
finally they said yes to a breaks the
deal and then delete it this house of
fools isn't fit for purpose and its
refusal to do its political
constitutional and moral duty has
resulted in a three year stalemate
reducing this once great country
to a global joke our remainder
Parliament has repeatedly betrayed
voters and democracy and is handling a
brexit is the greatest political
embarrassment of modern times it's done
everything in its power to wreck a deal
and no deal and an election all of which
were mandated by the people and even
though they have no mandate for a second
referendum or canceling brexit they're
amending their way to it which is why
one brexit is done there must be a
committee of inquiry into how our
elected representatives turned brigs it
into a national humiliation this
Parliament is rotten
we need an election right now not just
to clear out the dross but to restore
faith in a political system that is
hideously broken now Carole you and I
have been discussing this for about
three and a half years time everybody
we've never agreed on anything I'm just
surprised that you're quite so vitriolic
today because you're nearly we you're
nearly winning I mean if the Prime
Minister had never said he was gonna die
in a ditch if it if he didn't get a deal
by the end of October actually though
there would now be a three week to
examine the bill and you'd be like but
do you not think that you know in the
eyes of the world
we have lost face and credibility
because of our Parliament at a time when
we needed it most
no we've lost facing credit
because we're split as a country we
completely spit the people are split the
government is split the opposition is
split we are split and that's why they
can't get anything through but he did
get the deal through this week and I've
no doubt it'll get amended as it goes
through but actually it does need proper
scrutiny but they're still playing games
and that the whole point of the game
scooted but no it's not proper scrutiny
because the one that when the last when
Chuy's amazed deal went through this
deal is a hundred and fifteen hundred
twelve hundred fifteen pages the last
year was five hundred ninety nine pages
now remember clearly remain of
politicians talking about it within
twenty four hours have been being given
it so there were they felt across enough
that to say it was terrible and rubbish
and should never get through so 112
pages isn't such a big ass to read in a
couple of days I don't think I think
you're both right I think you're both
right I don't think you're right with a
Committee of Inquiry let's just once
we've got done let's move on and Greg
you say you'd be alright if we had
another couple of weeks or whatever why
why isn't three days enough we have paid
these politicians a minimum of 77
thousand pounds each per annum for three
and a half years many of them get a lot
more and now we're asking them to put in
a double shift businessmen and women
when they see an opportunity they work
through the night with the team of
lawyers and they buy a company or they
say then what what needs to be discussed
great but it hasn't been what you
possibly need to know they've got to go
through the actual words are gonna go
few bill will take time and then we'll
be scooting some of it will be improved
someone we change but we do it on every
other piece of legislation no we don't
Ben Act sorry accused of not using to a
processor man look this the only reason
why we're in this mess is because of the
idea of respecting the will of the
majority the 52% so the only question is
do the 52% support the deal that Boris
Johnson's just negotiated the answer is
no now you're Faraj the head of the art
nigel Faraj the head of the unofficial
leave campaign called it they were
called it the second worst deal in
history he's not you're now quoting
that's the point that is the point
Wilson had a major figure within the dup
the unionists in Northern Ireland said
that it said that they will not accept
it because it goes against the
fundamental principles of unionism but
Lord Trimble who was a unionist hero
said this deal is completely within the
spirit of the Good Friday Agreement and
the DUP does not speak for every year
the deal Boris Johnson's just signed
says the Northern Ireland follows the
regulations of the EU but is unable to
influence them at all because it will no
longer have representation in Brussels
so you've got a significant portion
significant spokespeople for the brexit
are saying this is not the will of the
people no two people yeah brexit party
so you're now relying on a Faraj to make
your own if you've got if you've got a
significant figure within within the
leave voting voting population who are
saying this does not represent what we
voted for you cannot call it the world
of people this is kind of like what do
you think should happen before I give my
view on this what you wants happen that
if there is no referendum on that deal
then that means that brexit essentially
becomes like signing a contract and
letting the other side of that contract
write the terms three years later and
then tell you you already signed
referendum on Boris Johnson's deal we
either leave on the toast Boris Johnson
is negotiated always saying I think we
need to be very careful I am a breakfast
here as most people will know but I
we're throwing around phrases now
willy-nilly like we've lost trust we've
lost faith House of fools and we are so
divided we saw it in Commons I think it
was yesterday the word trait have been
thrown across the Commons floor and I
really do feel that we need to proceed
with caution in terms of language used
in terms of who we're listening to and
how they are presenting their arguments
because to me there are so many personal
agendas at play now from all aspects
from both sides and so many people
you're saying you know the 52% they
don't want this deal that's not the case
I think what's happening there is a
furthering of agendas in all quarters
now and I actually think that the brexit
party they really need
with caution because hopefully what's
going to happen next or predictably
what's going to happen next will be some
form of general election and what will
happen the brexit party or at risk of
actually splitting the brexit vote which
will of course then lead to a lab of
government and can I ask you about this
which I want to coming down the way you
said you were talk about the use of the
word traitors do you not think you know
we can't we can't become a PC about the
word traitors do you not think it's
traitorous that some of our politicians
and MPs have actually traveled to Europe
to France and to the EU to talk to EU
bosses about how best direct brexit I
think I think it's people we have a
remain Parliament in a predominantly
leave contrariness so there is
significant contradictions and conflicts
there so I understand that if someone is
a pure out-and-out remainer they're
going to fight for their cause and I
don't like it because it's not the cause
on the side of the argument that I'm on
but I understand it to your point I do I
believe it's fundamentally wrong that
you would have a second referendum with
remain on the ballot paper without
having implemented we have to deal with
that as a concept I've just shown that
the brexit voting population is split
and what we want what they want polls
have been done showing that 69% we leave
means leave Nigel Rogers former
organization says that 69% of lis voters
want no deal whereas 15% would rather
delay brexit to avoid no deal which
means they want fundamentally
incompatible things so the name to then
claim that okay so here's the point if
you have a referendum between leave
options you're saying let's find out
what the first choice of a majority of
52% is a majority of 52% is not a
majority the biggest poll that has been
done on brexit was done by comrades two
weeks ago 26,000 people and and of them
54% said the result of the referendum
had to be honored you said you said
we're in this mess because we respected
the majority how would you have
elections the minority wins you're not
understanding the point no I understand
what you said no it was it was a
complete sentence it was a complete set
we're in this mess because we were spit
on what that wasn't all sentence
there was it that wasn't the full
sentence we're in this mess because
we're trying to respect the majority but
the majority want incompatible things
what you want to do it all again I would
mind a people's vote I think much more
likely is we're gonna get an election
and I think an election will be bizarre
because I everything you look at says if
the black sit party stand and the take
of enough votes from the tours which I
think they will you get this very
strange and I don't think the Labour
Party will win as you do they would but
some of those constituencies are such
strong labour seats that you can take
off 10,000 votes and they still win
well no I think you'll end up with a
another hung column I think it'll be all
over the place and I'm not sure it'll
solve the issue but I think that's where
we'll go
I think either later this year early
next year we will have a general
election can we just look at what Mervyn
King is saying about upon that what he
thinks needs to fall that boss of the
Bank of England well it would be really
nice to have to be able to stop talking
about it I think everyone is completely
fed up with what's going on you can't
have a parliament that can do only one
thing which is to vote against every
conceivable alternative I've said before
we need a new Parliament and I think we
need an election where it's clear which
people believe in remain and which
people believe in leaving Parliament's
brought this on itself and frankly the
sooner we can get rid of this the better
okay I mean he's basically saying it's
not fit for purpose and I suppose what
Boris has done in his rush with the the
October 31st deadline he's actually made
remain as come out of the closet
pretending that this is all about
democracy and actually they just do not
want to leave it's as simple as that